ognuno di noi ha delle sensibilità
particolari io amo passeggiare scoprire
posti nuovi incontrare persone che hanno
il sole il vento la terra tra le dita
amo vedere con i miei occhi i paesaggi
dall'alto e sentire quel profumo di
buono che c'è nell'aria quando sei lì
proprio dove vuoi essere ho scoperto
poco a poco che la mia è un'anima da
cercatrice d'oro quando ad un certo
punto della mia vita ho capito che il
lavoro che avevo non faceva per me e che
quindi è arrivato il momento di cambiare
strada
mi sono sentita come quella cercatore
d'oro che vuole arrivare in cima alla
montagna
anzi dentro la montagna io ero però
ancora in pianura a chilometri di
distanza
non sapevo dove fosse la miniera non
sapevo che avrei incontrato lungo il
cammino ma aveva una grande fiducia
nella mia intuizione
questa è una cosa che ognuno di noi ha
almeno in una certa misura
io ho capito strada facendo che la mia
anima da cercatrice d'oro mi piaceva
esplorato il territorio in cui ero nata
e no visto le bellezze e volevo che
altri partecipassero dello stesso
sguardo è che chi ci vive o ci passa o
ci capita per puro caso potesse godere
di quelle pepite come leggo devo io
pepite spesso piccole nascoste spesso
non sufficientemente valorizzate ho
cominciato trovandone una poi un'altra
poi un sacco intero e la cosa bella è
che mi sono resa conto ad un certo punto
che ero in grado di far dialogare quei
piccoli gioielli tra di loro perché la
bellezza si sa spesso contagiosa e
cominciata così un'avventura che va
avanti da più di tre anni e va a gonfie
vele le pepite che ho incontrato sul mio
cammino sono tutte le realtà del
trentino alto adige che si occupano in
maniera autentica di bambini e di
famiglie e come potete immaginare questo
è un interesse piuttosto ampio
il problema principale dei genitori o
degli adulti di riferimento è che
spesso non sanno dove andare non
conoscono il territorio sono ripetitivi
e soprattutto non amano affatto le
sorprese eppure il nostro territorio è
un utente ca miniera di luoghi davvero
incantevoli me ne faccio conoscere
alcuni c'è una panchina dove quando
arrivi ti sembra di essere il padrone
del mondo
quando sei lì nient'altro esiste c'è una
miniera la casa dei sette nani con i
mantelli le tazzine e dei piccoli
lettini ci sono torrenti da esplorare e
pozze color smeraldo da saltarci dentro
e un lago da percorrere in kayak che ti
sembra di essere nel grand canyon ci
sono cani da valanga che ti vengono a
cercare quando ti nascondi dentro la
neve e strumenti musicali sconosciuti da
suonare in una giornata di pioggia
ci sono insomma ogni giorno in tanti
angoli del trentino alto adige dei
luoghi incantevoli che possono regalare
delle esperienze indimenticabili sia ai
grandi che ai piccoli grande territorio
grande opportunità ma torniamo al punto
come farne un lavoro la chiave era
diventare un ambasciatrice del
territorio descriverlo in maniera
veritiera stimolare e promuovere le
realtà più belle coinvolgere le persone
facendo venire loro la voglia di andare
in quei posti vederli con i propri occhi
una delle prime cose di cui mi sono resa
conto quando ho cominciato questa
avventura è che accanto all'intuizione e
alla capacità di cogliere la qualità
delle proposte
ero capace di fare bene un'altra cosa a
raccontarlo agli altri non so se tutti
voi siete d'accordo con me ma io sono
convinta che una cosa quando viene
condivisa diventi più bella e più
preziosa e sapevo farlo e funzionava
perché poi quelle persone quando
leggevano il mio racconto in quei posti
ci andavano davvero e trovavano conferma
il mio racconto e me lo dicevano e lo
dicevano agli altri
e la cosa funzionava tanto e funziona
tuttora che spesso e volentieri gli
operatori e specialmente quelli più
piccoli
mi chiamavano per dire a raccontarmi che
improvvisamente avevano registrato il
tutto esaurito e anzi mi chiedevano
ormai a una prassi consolidata di
avvertirli in caso di una nuova
recensione per essere pronti a ricevere
tutte quelle persone com'è che si
chiedevano improvvisamente in una grigia
giornata di novembre arrivano un sacco
di telefonate di prenotazione per i
nostri tavoli perché improvvisamente
tutti chiedono del dell'asino galileo
se ciò in fattoria e perché tra le tante
proposte del menu vogliono tutti i
giochi realizzati con le ortiche il
passaparola cresceva rapidamente
il progetto è stato recepito dagli
utenti con grande entusiasmo e poi anche
dagli operatori che hanno cominciato a
chiederci e il silvia racconta anche me
avrete notato che ogni tanto dico io e
ogni tanto dico noi
ho cominciato infatti da sola ma ben
presto lungo il cammino si sono aggiunti
altri cercatori d'oro
ora siamo un gruppo una squadra che va
ogni giorno alla ricerca di nuove pepite
condividiamo la stessa passione la
fiducia nelle cose ben fatte e la
certezza che raccontarle serve a chi le
crea
e a chi ne gode non è stato sempre un
cammino semplice perché io volevo
mantenere le promesse fatte inizialmente
quando leggo qualcosa voglio poterci
credere
e lo stesso volevo che venisse con le
persone che avevano fiducia in me ho
rinunciato quindi a budget considerevoli
quando mi chiedevano di promuovere delle
realtà a mio avviso non meritevoli come
avrete intuito il denaro per me non è la
priorità
la priorità per me
mantenere la reputazione una reputazione
costruita ogni giorno passo dopo passo
con fatica quando uno si scopre
cercatore d'oro poi lo rimane per sempre
e ha due possibilità o costruire un
deposito come zio paperone oppure
reinvestire con le pepite nel territorio
con nuovi progetti da condividere
un'altra volta il successo di pubblico
la risposta del pubblico mi ha convinto
a cominciare un'altra volta a iniziare
una nuova avventura sta partendo proprio
in questi mesi sta prendendo concretezza
un'altra idea un portale un sito
dedicato ai grandi perché di tesori ce
ne sono tanti ma una giornata o un luogo
indimenticabile è un regalo ad ogni età
la morale della storia io non lo so se
c'è però mi ripeto spesso che in un
periodo storico che ha messo in crisi
più di una persona e che di certo non
brilla per la promozione di nuove
iniziative è ancora possibile provare a
volare
io avevo un nido stabile e sicuro l'ho
lasciato per il mio volo e questo volo
alla portata di chiunque
chiunque creda nelle proprie idee chi
abbia voglia di investire tempo e fatica
è semplicemente questa la mia ricetta la
ricetta per imparare a spiegare le
proprie ali
grazie
[Applauso]